Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
Specifically it is the 323rd consecutive Tuesday I have made a vlogbrothers video
except for one Tuesday when I had meningitis and another Tuesday when I had a Labyrinthitis
a disease with a very metaphorically resonant name but an extremely low pleasantness factor
What I'm getting at is that I usually upload these videos on time because I am a punctual person
Like I joined conference calls exactly one minute before the call was supposed to begin
I arrived at the doctor's office exactly 15 minutes early in case there's paperwork to fill out
And I must arrive at the airport at least 90 minutes before my flight is scheduled to depart
and when I say must I mean MUST like if I don't there is a five alarm fire in my brain now
There's this line in the Great Gatsby where Nick says everyone suspects himself of at least one of the cardinal virtues
And this is mine
I am one of the few honest people I have ever known
And that's nice Nick, that's a nice sentiment
but do you show up at Gatsby's house at the exact moment the invitation indicated the party would begin because I would punctuality is the
Cardinal virtue I suspect myself of I might not be calm I might not be pleasant I might not be good
But I will be on time
I also really like it when other people value punctuality like rosianna once called punctuality the most important commandment on the tablets
And I'm not sure she was kidding
She's always two minutes early two conference calls to me being punctual is a way of saying to other people I value your time enough
To show up when we agreed to show up or even slightly earlier
And I think that's important because ultimately time is all we have it is
overwhelmingly the most important human resource you know sometimes you identify so closely with an ideal that it becomes part of how you
Understand yourself like when I think about Who I am I think I'm a husband
I'm a father and I am a punctual person and once you get to that point like I don't just believe punctuality is
Unambiguously good. I believe it is inseparable from what constitutes good
It's difficult to listen to voices that disagree with you let alone take them
seriously
Right I mean who could be opposed to punctuality
E.B White as it turns out who is best known today as the author of Charlotte's Web
But also was a brilliant magazine writer
And I was recently reading a collection of his in which he wrote we teach our child many things
I don't believe in and almost nothing I do believe in we teach punctuality
particularly if the enforcement of it disturbs the peace
My father taught me by example that the greatest defeat in life was to miss a train only after many years
Did I learn that an escaping train carries away with it?
Nothing vital to my health railroad trains are such magnificent objects. We commonly mistake them for destiny
I've always defended my punctuality absolutism by saying it's about respecting other people and their time
But if I'm yelling at my family to get in the car
So we're not 86 minutes early for a flight am I really respecting people and their time or am
I just disturbing the peace now
I've never missed a train or for that matter of flight
But until I read those lines it had literally never occurred to me that an escaping train carries with it nothing vital to my health
But it doesn't of course. I still value punctuality, but lately I've been thinking that as with so many things
Extreme punctuality can become a vice even when what you worship is good and Noble
It doesn't always make you better or nobler all right. I have to go pack for our Spring Break vacation
We fly out in the morning. I'm not gonna miss the flight or anything, but I am gonna try to be less early Hank
I'll see you on Friday